[Music]
near the end of chapter nine in ursula k
le guin's second earth sea novel the
tombs of ottawan within the scope of a
single paragraph there's something
incredibly important sketched out there
that ged
explains a little bit in ways that
connected to what's been going on
beforehand
and prefiguring what's going to happen
right after that their escape from the
tombs and the beginning of a new life
together
and it centers around one word trust and
ged makes very clear at the start
that
he says call it trust that is one of its
names so
it's something that could be called by
other names as well this is not a very
narrow and clearly defined notion
instead what he's what he's signaling
is a complex reality something that has
built up between them and which now
places itself you could say
at their disposal he says
it is a very great thing so
we can talk about the power of trust
and we could talk about all sorts of
other synonyms i mentioned capacity
already a sort of readiness a sort of
responsiveness to the other a
reliability
a confidence that comes about through
knowing that you're in
some sort of relationship that has a
foundation that that can be
you know expected to go on and as he
says that without this
each of them
is weak and in fact in that that very
chapter what we see is
tenar arha coming to
ged
for a kind of consolation and to express
her own helplessness the it seems to her
that the old masters the nameless ones
are actually dead because the other high
priestess who doesn't really believe in
them is in there digging up the fake
grave desecrating it and and she's
probably going to either force tenor to
kill ged or to die herself as mana has
pointed out so she's coming to get and
saying i can't actually deal with this
and get is there
for her just as she has been there for
get bringing him food and water and even
more importantly companionship
so
with trust he says each of them has a
strength that they wouldn't have on
their own now notice this this is not
the
you know
you know separate we're weak united
we're strong as if somehow just being
united or being together makes each
individual strong
there's three things here there's tenar
there's ged and there is the trust
uniting them the trust between them the
trust that has developed which is not a
person but is something like an entity
there's actually a fourth entity as
we're going to talk about in just a
moment that's going to help them out of
there and then get recounts
how this developed and you can read
backwards into the previous chapters
to see this happening right they develop
a closer and closer connection they
reveal
more and more of themselves it begins
rather antagonistically as ged himself
says
i came here as a thief an enemy armed
against you right and she was as well
but she showed him mercy and trusted him
and then from the moment that he fell
into her power he says that
he trusted her from the start and
there's a nice
additional line i trusted you from the
first time i saw your face for one
moment in the cave beneath the tombs
beautiful in darkness right so he's is
he engaging in some flattery or is he
just saying that she is indeed somebody
who is beautiful
they have come to know each other
they've come to
trust each other
and he goes on and he says listen you've
already proven
your trust to me how has she done that
well by
placing him in you know safe places like
taking him from the painted room to the
treasure room
by bringing him food
which she had to
sacrifice on her own part fasting so
that he could eat by bringing him water
by protecting him from castle and the
others
who would kill him right
so she's already done quite a lot and
perhaps even
by asking him the questions by engaging
in conversation with him by being
another human being
with him
now it's time he says that he proves it
and so what does he actually do
he says i have made no return of that
trust i will give you what i have to
give and so he does two things
he says
my true name
is get
we know the importance of true names
both in the wizard of earthsea and of
course in the the earlier story the rule
of names but there's also a passage in
which he tells her about names and why
ordinary people in earth sea don't give
out their names in what she calls the
inner lands but especially wizards don't
give out their names and so he is giving
her
his name he is making
himself vulnerable to her in a way that
she'll actually
without meaning to test later on when
she uses his true name when he's in
disguise
so he's gonna do that but he also takes
the
fragments of the ring of ereth akba
and he says you've already got the one
you took for me i discovered this in the
treasures this is what i came to seek
it's yours i trust you with it
and so he's giving back to her
um what he can
and this is kind of an interesting thing
to point out a bit of a digression but
when it comes to
trusting other people developing this
sort of relationship that is not just
rer tener and ged but le guin is
pointing at something that's really
fundamental to human existence here
we we often don't give and take at the
same time one gives before
or it's over the course of time and we
don't always give the same things do we
it's it's not possible
very often that for there to be strict
equality perfect reciprocity sometimes
one will give more one will give less
and it depends you know who's giving
more depends on the perspective that
you're you're looking at doesn't it
so this is a very important uh set of
points
now trust
allows them
to get themselves out of their situation
but how does it do so as as they say
before
ged
says
here we go a little bit earlier tenar
says they would not let us get out ever
right the powers the the dark ones and
he says perhaps not yet it's worth
trying
you
tenar have knowledge i ged have skill
and between us we have he paused she
brings up the third thing
we have the ring of ereth akba which is
not yet
reformed at this point in time it's
still broken and this is where he says
yes that but i thought of another thing
between us call it trust so the trust
between them
is what allows her knowledge of the
labyrinth
of the under tombs of the ways things
work in the the temples and kargish
society to be useful his skill his
magical capacities which he's already
using to hold back the
old powers of the earth that otherwise
would be would be destroying them
and then they have the ring which in the
very
next part of the
following chapter is going to be
reformed through a
spell of patterning on the part of ged
and then worn by tenor on her arm it's
given to her
so
they do have all these things these
advantages but
none of them would be
really
effective
on their own
and all together as the three without
this trust between them this is what
permits them
not just to act as one or be a unit or
something like that they actually have
to reinforce each other as things are
going on um ged at one point in time has
to be very forceful with with tenar to
get her to to come with him
with that they can escape the tombs and
they can face
the power the immense power in their
most powerful place
of the nameless ones the old masters the
uh
old powers of the earth that arha is the
priestess of
whose wrath is being turned against both
of them
so this is what allows them to make it
out of that place
once they do
trust comes up again in another set of
important ways there's a very
interesting discussion they're hungry
and
tenner asks well you know can't you just
make some magic and make some food and
gad says well
no
that i could but it's illusion and you'd
still be hungry and then
she also says
[Music]
here we go can you find food for us
hunting takes time and weapons i meant
with you know spells and he says i can
call a rabbit the rabbits are coming out
of their holes all around us evening's
their time i could call one by name and
he'd come
but would you catch and skin and broil a
rabbit that you'd called to you thus
perhaps if you were starving
but it would be a breaking of trust i
think
and this doesn't mean that they don't
actually call a rabbit but they don't
kill the rabbit in fact he teaches her
the word
in the old speech right the true speech
for rabbit and she does call a rabbit by
them but they
you know um
here we go
she says that's lovely could i do that
the rabbit's name is a secret
and all of that
so
why not
call a rabbit well because they're not
in dire necessity
if they were then that would be
in some respect allowable but it would
still be a breach
of trust
on the part of get
using his magic to compel something to
give itself
to him
they all there's also a lot more about
ged helping tenar
face her future and i really think
there's a couple points that we should
signal here
so in the end of chapter 11
he's he's uh telling her about the
islands of earth sea
um
she knew he was trying to hearten her
but she had left joy up in the mountains
in the twilight valley of the stream
there was a dread in her now that grew
and grew all that lay ahead of her was
unknown she knew nothing but the desert
and the tombs what good was that she
knew the turnings of a ruined maze she
knew the dances danced before a fallen
altar she knew nothing of forests or
cities or the hearts of men she said
suddenly will you stay with me there
and he says tenor i go where i'm sent i
follow my calling
it has not yet let me stay in any land
for long do you see that i do what i
must do
where i go i must go along
so
that that sounds like he's saying well
it's been cool uh kid but i i gotta i
gotta go do my job right but immediately
after that he says something to her that
reinforces this trust
so long as you need me i will be with
you in hovnor
and if you ever need me again call me i
will come i would come from my grave if
you called me tenar but i cannot stay
with you so this is a promise that he's
making
about
coming being with her while she needs
him but not staying for life
so
this is a you know very important way of
understanding trust the other thing that
happens
is there's a point where
she actually considers
killing him
right
he had made her follow him he had called
her by name and she had come crouching
to his hand as the little wild desert
rabbit had come to him out of the dark
and now that he had the ring now that
the tombs were in ruin and their
priestess foresworn now he didn't need
her and went away where she could not
follow he would not stay with her he had
fooled her and would leave her desolate
she plucked the little steel dagger
she'd given him he moved no more than a
robed statue and there's there's more
discussion of this and then he simply
turns and says tenor as if in greeting
and reached up his hand to touch the
band of pierced and carve in silver on
her wrist he did this as if reassuring
himself
trustingly he trusts her
not to
kill him not to
out of her grief out of her desolation
out of her despair to turn on him
and so
she ends up trusting him yet once again
because he trusts her they have built up
this thing between them that even though
it doesn't take on exactly the contours
that she would desire
it still suffices so
trust
becomes an incredibly
powerful
and important theme
within this this narrative
you